I now give the floor to his Excellency
Mr Vladimir zielinski the president of
Ukraine
you have the floor sir
thank you very much dear Madam chairman
Mr Secretary General
distinguished members of the security
Council and other members of this
meeting thank you very much for this
opportunity I'm sure that all the
representatives of the United Nation
member states will hear me today
yesterday I returned from our city of
butcher recently liberated from Russian
troops not far from Kiev so there is not
a single crime that they would not
commit there the Russian military
searched for and purposefully killed
anyone who served our country they
killed short and killed women outside
their houses when they just tried to
call someone who is alive they killed
entire families adults and children and
they tried to burn the bodies I am
addressing you on behalf of the people
who honor the memory of the disease
every single day in the memory of the
civilians who died who were shot and
killed in the back of their head after
being tortured some of them were shot on
the streets others were thrown into the
wells so they died there in suffering
they were killed in their Apartments
houses blowing up grenades the civilians
were crushed by tanks while sitting in
their cars in the middle of the road
just for their pleasure they cut off
limbs cut their throat slashed their
throats women were raped and killed in
front of their children they were their
tongues were pulled out only because the
aggressor did not hear what they wanted
to hear from them so this is no
different from other terrorists such as
daesh who occupied some territories and
here it is done by a member of the
United Nations security Council
destroying internal Unity borders
countries and taking the right of more
than dozen of countries who are
self-determined and indeterminants they
pursue a consistent policy of destroying
ethnic and religious diversity then
inflame Wars and deliberately lead them
in such a way that to kill as many
regular civilians and cities the two
leave the country where they deploy
their troops in Ruins and filled with
mass Graves you all see that and they
support hatred at the level of the state
and seek to export it to other countries
through their system of propaganda and
political corruption they provoke a
global food crisis that could lead to
famine in Africa Asia and other
countries and will surely end in
large-scape political chaos in many
countries were to and destroying their
domestic security so where is the
security that the security Council needs
to guarantee it's not there although
there is a security Council
and so where is the Peace where are
those guarantees that the United Nation
needs to guarantee it is obvious that
the key institution of the world which
must ensure the coercion of any
aggressive is simply cannot work
effectively now the worlds can see that
the Russian what Russian military did in
butcher while keeping the city under
their occupation but the world has yet
to see what they have done in other
occupied cities and regions of our
country
geography might be different of various
but cruelty is the same crimes are the
same and accountability must be
inevitable ladies and gentlemen I would
like to remind you of Article 1 chapter
1 of the UN Charter what is the purpose
of our organization its purpose is to
maintain peace and make sure that peace
is adhered to and now that you're in
charge is violated literally starting
with the article one and if so what is
the point of all other articles today as
a result of Russia's actions in our
country in Ukraine the most terrible war
crimes of all times are we see since
their end of World War II and they are
being committed Russians troops are
deliberately destroying United Ukrainian
cities to ashes by with artillery and
airstrike they are deliberately blocking
City creating masturbation they
deliberately shoot Columns of civilians
on the road trying to escape from the
territory of History hostilities they
even deliberately blow up shelters where
civilians hide from airstrike they are
deliberately creating conditions in the
temporarily occupied territory so that
as many civilians as possible are killed
there the massacre in our city of
butcher is only one unfortunately only
one of many examples of what the
occupiers have been doing on our land
for the past 41 days and there there are
many more cities similar places where
the world will has yet to learn the full
truth
and dozens other Ukrainian communities
each of them is similar to bucha I know
and you know perfectly well what the
representatives of Russia will say in
response to the accusations of these
crimes they have said that many times
the most significant was after their
shooting down of the Malaysian Boeing
over donbass by Russian forces with
Russian weapons or during the war in
Syria they will blame everyone just to
justify their own actions they will say
that there are various
versions different versions and it is
impossible to establish which one of
those versions is true they will even
say that the bodies were of those skills
were allegedly thrown away okay and all
videos are staged but it is 2022 now we
have conclusive evidence so there are
satellite images we can conduct full and
transparent investigation that is what
we are interested in maximum access for
journalists maximum cooperation with
International institutions involvement
of the international criminal court
complete truth and full accountability
I'm sure that every member state of the
UN should be interested in this for what
in order to punish once for and for all
those who consider themselves privileged
and believe that they can get away with
anything so show all the other potential
war criminals in the world how they will
be punished if the biggest one is
punished then everyone is punished and
why did Ukraine came to come to Ukraine
I will tell you because Russia lead
Russia's leadership feels like
colonizers in ancient times they need
our wealth our people Russia has already
deported hundreds of thousands of our
citizens to their country they abducted
more than 2 000 children just simply
conducted that those children and
continue to do so Russia wants to turn
Ukraine into silent slaves the Russian
military are looting openly the cities
and Villages there they have captured
this is wide scale looting they are
stealing everything starting with food
ending with earrings gold earrings that
are pulled out with and covered with
blood we are dealing with a state that
is turning the veto into the U.N
security Council into the right to Die
the this undermines the whole
architecture of Global Security it
allows to to go out punished so they are
destroying everything that they can so
this if we if this continues there the
countries will be rely only on the power
of their own arms to ensure their
security and not on international law
not rely on International institutions
the United Nations can be on simply
closed ladies and gentlemen are you
ready to close the U.N do you think that
the time of international law is gone if
your answer is no then you need to act
immediately the UN
Charter must be restored immediately the
U.N system must be reformed immediately
so that the veto is not the right to die
that there is a fair representation in
the security Council of all region of
the world the aggressive must be brought
to peace immediate deadly determination
is needed the massacre from Syria to
Somali Somalia from Afghanistan to Yemen
and Libya that should have been stopped
a long time ago to tell you the truth if
tyranny had at least once received such
a response to the war it had be we had
reached it would have ceased to exist an
honest peace had been guaranteed after
it and the world would have changed for
sure and then perhaps there would not be
war in my country against our people
about against Ukrainian people against
our citizens but the world watched and
did not want to see either the
occupation of Crimea or the war against
Georgia or taking the entire
transistoria from Moldova and how Russia
Was preparing with the basis for other
conflicts and Wars near their borders
how to stop it right away the Russian
military and those who gave them orders
must be brought to Justice immediately
for war crimes in Ukraine anyone who has
given criminal orders and carried out
them by killing our people will be
brought before the tribe but you know
which should be similar to the Nuremberg
tribunals I would like to remind Russian
diplomas that men like Von rib and Trump
has not escaped punishment after for
crimes in World War II I would also like
to remind you that Adolf artman also did
not
go did not go unpunished nobody of them
escaped the punishment but the main
thing is today is to it's time to
transform the system the United Nations
so therefore I propose to convince
Global conference and we can do it here
in peaceful cave in order to determine
how we are going to reform the world
security system how we will rely uh how
do we establish guarantee of recognition
of borders and integrity of states and
countries how we will serve the rule of
international law it is now clear that
the ghost set in San Francisco in 1945
for the creation of a Global Security
International Organization have not been
achieved and it is impossible to achieve
them without reforms therefore we must
do everything in our power to pass on to
the next generation an effective U.N
with the ability to respond preventively
to security challenges and thus
guarantee peace prevent aggression and
force aggressors to peace have the
determination and ability to buy punish
if the principles of Peace are violated
there can be no more exceptions or
privileges everybody must be equal all
participants of international relations
regardless of economic strength
geographical area and individual
ambitions
power of Peace must become dominant the
power of justice and the security
power as Humanity has always dreamed of
it Ukraine is ready to provide a
platform for one of the main offices of
the newly updated security system as
similar to the Geneva office that deals
with human rights and Nairobi office
that deals with Environmental Protection
and in key we can have
U24 office that can specialize in
preventive measures to maintain peace I
would like to remind you of our peaceful
mission in Afghanistan when we
ukrainians evacuated from that country
over thousands more than one thousand
people from uh with at our own extent it
was a very difficult phase and Ukraine
came to their help we took in people of
different nationalities ethnic groups
different is Afghan citizens of the the
European of European countries U.S
Canada we did not look who needed
help was it one of our own or somebody
else we helped all of them we saved
everyone every time there was a need
everyone in the world would be confident
that Health could would come the world
would be definitely safer therefore
Ukraine has the the moral right to
propose a reform of the world security
system we have proven that we helped
others not only happy time but in dark
times too and now we need decisions from
the security Council for peace in
Ukraine if you do not know how to uh to
make this decision you can do two things
either remove Russia as an aggressor and
a source of War
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own war and then do
everything that we can do to establish
peace or the other option is please show
how we can uh reform or change dissolve
yourself and and work for peace or if
there is no alternative and no option
then the next option would be dissolve
yourself altogether and I know that you
can admit that if there is nothing that
you can do besides conversation we need
peace we Ukraine P need peace Europe
needs peace and the world needs peace
and finally I would kindly ask you very
much to watch this short video
please give us one more minute of your
time the video that we uh want to show
that one one country can violate rights
and that's the result of being
unpunished if possible please watch this
video because it is impossible to get
everyone to come to our country and see
it with your own eyes therefore I would
ask you to watch this video thank you
very much
foreign
[Applause]